et la nouvelle en fox autour de la
guerre en ukraine ce soir elle concerne
le président tchétchène ramzan kadirov
antoine oui absolument marion bonsoir à
vous et bonsoir à tous et autour d'une
photo en particulier que vous allez
apercevoir derrière moi celle du leader
tchétchène vous le voyez ici à genoux en
train de prier dans une prête dans une
station-service on rappelle que ramzan
kadirov et tchétchènes qu'il est
également musulmans d'où cette prière
cette photo a été relayée sur twitter
vous le voyez avec la traduction de ce
tweet que je vous lis kadirov
désespèrement faire croire qu'il se bat
en ukraine il affirme qu'il est à
marioupol mais ils ne réalisent pas
qu'il n'y a pas de station roos nef en
ukraine alors kadirov était-il en
ukraine au moment de sa prière bien pour
le savoir il faut remonter à la source
même de cette image est la source de
cette image est en réalité une capture
d'écran d'une vidéo une vidéo d'un peu
plus de deux minutes publiée sur des
chaînes télégramme les chaînes
télégramme pro tchétchènes et notamment
celle de duca le cas de celle d'un bras
droit de kadirov que vous apercevez ici
qui s'appelle magomed d'aude off on le
voit ici c'est cette vidéo ici que vous
apercevez ici à info ou intox on a pu
géolocaliser la station service en
question vous avez pu apercevoir dans la
première photo est effectivement elle ne
se trouve pas en ukraine elle se trouve
ici vous le voyez en russie près de
rostov sur le don c'est à dire à peu
près là c'est en réalité à 239 km à
l'est de marioupol ramzan kadirov on
n'était donc pas en ukraine au moment où
il a pris ça c'est pour la paix le
premier élément on pourrait donc croire
que le leader tchétchène à montils
ouvertement mais là où c'est plus
compliqué marion c'est que kadirov n'a
jamais affirmé qu'il se trouvait en
ukraine et encore moins à marioupol lors
de cette prière sur la chaîne pro
kadirov la légende de la vidéo que je
vous ai que je vous ai montré dit bref
chronique du voyage à marioupol ces
images sont donc censés le montrer sur
la route de la ville donc direction
mario paul depuis grozny la capitale de
tchétchénie et si on reprend notre petit
outil de géolocalisation
on voit que et bien sûr la vidéo au
départ que je vais vous remonterez ici
au départ du palais présidentiel que
vous apercevez ici il fait jour on voit
qu'il fait jour et lorsqu'il prit en
revanche vous en apercevez il fait nuit
si on reprend notre petit trajet des
jeux accusations on se rend compte qu'il
ya à peu près 9 heures de route entre
les deux points que j'ai pu vous montrer
ça colle donc avec la prière du soir
vous l'avez compris marion tant que
dirait on était pas en ukraine au moment
de cette prière mais la question c'est
est ce qu'il s'est vraiment finalement
rendu en ukraine à mariupol et oui c'est
là toute la question la question
centrale même ramzan kadirov lui n'a
jamais relayé lui même le contenu de le
contenu de cette à ces dates ni ne l'a
pas relié sur sa chaîne télégramme en
revanche il a relayé une autre vidéo à
peu près la même la même vidéo sur sa
chaîne télégramme que voici que je que
je vais que je vais vous montrer un peu
plus tôt il a relayé une vidéo d'un peu
plus de cinq minutes que je vais essayer
de remonter elle est un peu un peu plus
haut dans les tweets on veut on va dans
les dents les messages télégramme qu'on
va essayer de montrer voilà c'est celle
qui est juste au dessus voilà il a
relayé cette vidéo qui fait donc un peu
plus le samu qui a été vue un peu plus
d'un million 800 mille fois et dans
cette vidéo on ne voit pas le moment où
lui-même pris près de 7 stations service
en revanche dans la vidéo que l'on voit
ici on le voit dans un quartier général
militaire il explique lui même ramzan
kadirov qu'il se trouvait à marioupol il
y aurait rencontré un certain andry
morte fit chef commandant de l'armée
russe sur le front de guerre du sud est
ainsi que des soldats russes et des
combattants tchétchènes les médias
russes deux sortes de son pote de leur
côté n'ont pas manqué évidemment de
relayer cette visite affirmant qu on le
voit que ramzan kadirov était venu
galvaniser les troupes à marioupol
pourtant attention aucune des vidéos
postées par les combattants pro russe ni
par les comptes pro tchétchènes ne
permet de vérifier qu il s'est donc
rendu à marioupol on se quitte pas là
dessus vous vouliez me parler d'une
autre à fox autour de l'ukraine oui
assez rapidement autour de cette photo
largement relayée en anglais notamment
sur twitter vouloir c'est celle d'un
chasseur ukrainien qui aurait qui a
touché vous le voyez avec son entrée
d'air de son recteur un panneau
signalant signalisation routière avec
cette légende et ce tweet plutôt les
chasseurs ukrainien volcy bas pour
échapper aux radars marion que l'un
d'entre eux a touché un panneau de
signalisation avec son entraîneur alors
ça paraît séduisant un an montre
l'héroïsme des pilotes ukrainiens mais
en fait avec une simple recherche
d'image inversé comme on le fait
régulièrement quand on track d un fox
comme nous
rend compte que ce n'est pas du tout le
cas cet incident est bien réelle mais
ils ne datent pas de cette de la guerre
en ukraine mais du 27 août 2001 vous
l'apercevez ici sur cet article lors
d'un exercice de l'armée l'ukraine 1
chasseurs soukhoï 27 saisons dont a bien
touché un panneau de signalisation ça
s'est passé sur une portion d'autoroute
fermée à la circulation entre kiev et la
ville de chop c'est ce qu'on apprend
dans cet article la chaîne de télévision
ukrainienne tch à d'ailleurs relier l
l'incident on va voir le chasseur vous
le voyez ont peut-être l'avoir
rapidement et ses hommes il touche
rapidement le panneau signalisation
attention donc aux biais de penser vous
l'avez compris merci beaucoup antoine
pour ce rappel rester avec nous dans
quelques minutes un nouveau journal
[Musique]